Hello everybody, Dr. Kevin Conner's here here with Dr. Kelly Halderwood.
She's worked in her clinic works as a researcher, no formulator still helps us in many ways.
Good friend for quite a many years.
We're going to talk about some new products that we have out right?
Two in my hands.
These are from professional health products and we had a collaboration with Conner's clinic and created the LX Acute.
There's a little bit of glare there, but LX Acute and LX Chronic.
And then the third product is AI.
So Dr. Conner's, oh, you have it.
Awesome.
Can you tell us why you developed this line?
Well, there is four line patients really.
I don't know.
Can non-line patients use this really for autoimmune patients?
Let's talk about that.
But the first two products, the Acute LX and the Chronic LX really have line patients in mind.
So Acute Lime.
So when we talk about live, we really talk about three phases of line.
I know in the general public, they call Acute Lime and Chronic Lime.
That's why we name the products act because most people know about that idea.
But we talk about a third phase of line, which is autoimmune line.
Hence today, AI on this.
So this can be used for anybody with any autoimmune case, not just line.
But what you do, what you're dealing with line, you're dealing with a biotoxin.
And typically, you know, when we say the word line, we're not just talking about Borrelia,
or if we were talking about 100 different co-infections that go along with it.
And people have a slew of those, whatever they have a diagnosis of line.
So you're trying to kill this pathogen, right?
So and we always talk about it in the Acute phase.
If you found out you just got bit by a deer chick and you got all these symptoms,
go to a medical doctor and get it antibiotic.
But you should also do things to boost your immune system.
So taking the Acute LX.
And certainly if, if I have an Acute case of line, when I take an antibiotic,
I'd actually take both of these.
Because they're both immune stimulants.
And this one is really the Acute LX has really created a design for that Acute infection.
Certainly could take this for other infections like viruses that are going around and such too.
But it was really designed for that Acute Bacterial infection.
It's got mushrooms, which are the polysaccharides.
It's got burmerated and cats clawed.
Great things like that that help kill infections.
And then the chronic LX is for the more stubborn cases that have been going on for a longer period of time.
And what it adds is some of the parasitic killers.
And some of the things that are got binders and some enzymes help break down the biofilm around these bacteria.
Yeah, I've never seen a product like this chronic LX.
I've never seen a product that has the, you know, the comprehensive ingredients.
And then the proprietary enzyme blend in there.
Like you're saying that the parasitic approach to, so this really, this is going to be a mainstay for people
that I see because I know that there's a lot that I'm grabbing so many different things, so many different products.
And it's all in one and now and right there.
Well, that's, I mean, that's a key thing is you could have a great protocol for a patient.
But if they have to take 10 different things, it's they are they're going to stick to it.
And can they afford it?
So when we design this, you know, when we talked about what we wanted in a perfect chronic line protocol.
It's like, can we get it all in one model? That was the challenge.
But, you know, we got the main things that we wanted in this product that would be for a chronic line patient.
And we are already seen for the good results with it. So it's exciting.
Awesome. And how about the, the AI?
Well, the AI is for that third phase of line and that, that we talk about.
So if a person has chronic line for a number of years, your body can start making antibodies to self tissue.
So why would it do that? Well, lime has the ability to hide inside of a cell once it goes intracellular.
Now my immune system can't kill it very well.
The antibiotics can't kill it intercellular either.
And over time, my, my body, my immune system, my B cells, my TH two side of my immune system will start making antibodies against self tissue.
Once you do that, you have to be very careful, stimulating immune response with any immune products like these.
When you're in an autoimmune phase, you can't really use these or any other immune stimulating products.
So how are you going to kill lime then? Well, you have to do it with things that aren't immune stimulators that are going to kill it directly.
That's why we created this. So this has things in it when that will decrease the inflammation around the where the live is found that will kill it directly that will
cause the enzyme blends that will help break up the biofilm around the line.
And we'll, we'll decrease that TH one side of the immune system, decrease that killer side so that you're not flaring this autoimmune reaction every time you're trying to kill something.
Well, long story short, this is really for, this could be used literally for anybody with any autoimmune condition.
But for people that don't do well with immune stimulants have chronic lime, but if I take cat's claw, I get, I get worse, then that's a sign that you need this product.
And you need to calm down that killer side of the immune system while you're still killing the lime, it's going to take longer, but these people have already been in the game for a long time.
And that's the product that you use.
Right. And that's a big mistake that we see over and over again is people with these autoimmune conditions, they're on just a ton of immune stimulants and they're helping their body.
And you taught me this long ago that they're helping their body kill itself. And so this is a, this is a product I've never seen product like this, but together I'm so excited that we actually have this tool.
There's so many people who are, who are going about treating their autoimmune condition in the wrong way a lot of even doctors and practitioners don't understand.
This is a line. So this is just kind of like a little preview, but we're going to do a longer educational series where we go in Dr. Conner's and you're going to go into a brief phases of line and talk about, I like get into those for an educational piece, but these products are available at your store, right, Dr. Conner's right now.
In our store, you could go to our clinic site, Conner's clinic, CEO and an ERS clinic, another upper right hand quarter, whatever it is, it's a shop, our store or whatever it says.
And I mean, the key component of the key take home, if you're like, well, how do I know what phase I'm in? Well, you know, you're in a cute phase, you just got bit, right, so then take the acute.
Well, I mean, the chronic, but how do I know, you know, if I'm not in autoimmune, well, when you take immune stimulants, do you feel worse? I do.
Well, then stop taking the immune stimulants because every time you're stimulating your immune system, you have you have self-antibitis, you'll kill that which we have self-antibitis against and you're killing yourself.
So that's where you get on the AI, and this aren't taking this, you will not hurt yourself with this, and it's going to take longer to kill it, but you're not going to kill yourself.
So those are all available in our store. A lot of other doctors are carried these products now, not just us, we're making it available to blind literate doctors everywhere through people.
Yeah, we've had a ton of sales, we've had a ton of practitioners know that you personally formulated these, and they're already on the shelves from California to North Carolina, all on the shelves.
So we're excited that we were able to get in collaboration with production health products and products, and that we are able to bring these products really revolutionary.
And I think that you're like you're saying a lot of people are taking immune skill and making some self-sperse.
This is really a great strategy for that. So this is just the first of more educational videos that we'll be doing, but thank you Dr. Conner for your time.
I'm really excited that these are out.
All right, thanks so much.
Thank you.